so last week I mentioned that I would be
significantly limiting my coverage of
the so-called Obama gate scandal because
floating these conspiracy theories is
how Donald Trump wins it's how Trump
distracts it's how Donald Trump creates
cover for himself and in this case
Donald Trump has failed on coronavirus
he's fired four inspectors general in
the last few months and the way Trump
distracts from this is to get media
debating Obama gate get media talking
about his supposedly taking
hydroxychloroquine so I'm going to do
this today because there's actually
something to tell you about which is a
leaked document that shows that Barack
Obama acted completely appropriately
back in 2016 and 2017 when it comes to
the Michael Flynn investigation now I
also you know there's people in my
audience who may not even really know
what the Obama gate scandal supposedly
is Donald Trump clearly doesn't really
understand it he called it the greatest
political crime in the history of the
United States and yet when he was asked
for an explanation of what crime was
committed Trump didn't know where he
refused to say and he went on to attack
the journalist who asked the question
but generally and I don't want to spend
an hour on this because it's just not
worth it but we do have news today
generally Obama gate is related to the
investigation into Donald Trump's
disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn and Michael
Flynn's eventual guilty pleas on on
multiple counts the allegations
generally speaking of Obama Gate our
Obama acted inappropriately
he pushed law enforcement to do this or
that to Flynn Obama was the puppeteer of
a political hack job on Flynn in order
to attack Trump even to remove Trump and
it was all illegal despite the fact that
we still don't have clarity on what
crimes supposedly were even committed if
you really want to know more about the
details you can find them but it's just
not even worth explaining it to you we
now have a released unredacted memo from
Barack Obama's then national security
adviser Susan Rice this is what's called
a contemporary contemporaneous memo it's
dated Friday January 20 2017 it's a
summary of her notes from the January
5th
the meeting that is the center of a lot
of this and again I I sort of don't want
to go deep on this because it's a huge
waste of time but I want to get some of
this on the record for everybody in the
letter in the memo that Susan Rice wrote
she says there was a briefing from the
intelligence community about Russian
hacking during 2016 and after that
briefing there was a meeting which she
participated in the meeting involved
President Barack Obama then FBI director
James Comey Deputy Attorney General
Sally Yates Obama's national security
adviser Susan Rice who wrote this memo
and Vice President Joe Biden so good we
know who was there Susan Rice goes on to
say President Obama began the
conversation by stressing his continued
commitment to ensuring every aspect of
this issue is handled by the
intelligence and law enforcement
communities by the book okay the
president stressed he is not asking
about initiating or instructing anything
from a law enforcement perspective he
reiterated that our law enforcement team
needs to proceed as it normally would by
the book it goes on to say Obama wants
to ensure that in their interactions
with the incoming Trump administration
they know if there are reasons they
should not share information fully about
Russia James Comey then confirmed they
will go by the book and added that he
has some concerns that incoming national
security adviser Michael Flynn is
speaking more frequently than would be
normal or typical with Russian
ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac and it could
be an issue when it comes to sensitive
information Comey said potentially the
outgoing administration the Obama
administration should be careful about
passing sensitive information related to
Russia to Michael Flynn because of the
unusual level of communication between
Flynn and the Russian ambassador it's
there in black and white Obama wanted
nothing special Comey had these concerns
period there is no crime there
particularly on the behalf of Barack
Obama the
only shocking thing about this letter is
how a politically and professionally
Barack Obama handled this which I know
seems inconceivable in the era of Donald
Trump now there's a few other things to
mention Barack Obama warned Donald Trump
about Michael Flynn during the
transition period if Barack Obama were
involved in shady business why on earth
would he call attention to it by
mentioning Michael Flynn to Donald Trump
why go to Trump and say be careful with
Flynn if Obama is the one working on a
criminal trumped up bogus hack job of
Michael Flynn it makes no sense now
lastly there are people arguing that the
proof that the FBI and trapped Michael
Flynn is there are notes from January
24th before a Michael Flynn
interrogation where they said one of the
goals of this interrogation is to get
Michael Flynn to lie and there are
people who are wildly saying that's
proof that it was a setup this is a
perjury trap this is entrapment I hate
to break it to you guys but this is
nothing controversial these are FBI
notes in advance of an interrogation
about their goals for the interrogation
it's done all the time Flynn had already
lied at that point and what they are
making reference to here is they want to
get Flynn's repeated lie on the record
this is not a perjury trap there is also
you know perjury trap has a very narrow
definition and it's when there is no
reason to suspect a crime has been
committed and you bring someone in for
an interview only to get them to lie
absent any information that they've
already lied in the past or have been
potentially involved in any other crime
999 out of a thousand times when the
term perjury trapped is perjury trap is
used it simply does not apply Michael
Flynn lied multiple times he pleaded
guilty to two counts he had denied that
he told kiss lyac to back off from
escalating the situation in response to
sanctions that was a lie he lied about a
follow-up phone call I think there was a
third matter Flynn lied about that I now
can't recall and given the number of
lies that Flynn told he actually got a
pretty damn good deal he's a retired US
general he got money from at least one
foreign government Turkey he could have
been charged with conspiracy he could
have been charged with failure to
register as a foreign agent like his
business partner Rafiki and did and in
the end he actually got a pretty good
deal lastly if james comey had it in for
trump and wanted hilary to win and this
flynn thing was part of that
why did Comey not once but twice hold an
optional press conference to talk about
the investigation into Hillary Clinton's
emails not once but twice including
right before the November election it
makes no sense it is a really dumb way
for Comey to hurt Trump and help Hillary
to hold two press conferences or press
briefings public statements talking
about the investigation into Hillary
Clinton's emails so this entire Obama
Gate thing has backfired
it has spectacularly imploded and very
quickly you were starting to see the
people around Donald Trump move on to
new things and it is all to distract
from Trump's horrifying pandemic
response this is how Trump wins every
document that comes out shows that
Barack Obama certainly committed no
crimes it shows James Comey handled this
in a way that correspondent with how you
would have to sensitively deal with
something when you know you have an
incoming national security official that
has to be investigated
it has evaporated before our very eyes
one of our sponsors is privacy calm
they're giving you $5.00 when you sign
up for their completely free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
I love using free trials because I know
I won't be charged when the trial is
over if I use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private by not telling companies who you
are you're keeping your bank or credit
card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft and it's
free there's no catch whatsoever but if
you want privacy also offers a $10 a
month plan that gives you one percent
cashback and lets you create 36 credit
cards a month and a $25 a month plan
tailored more for small businesses where
you can create 60 card numbers a month
and much more but definitely go ahead
and at least get started with the free
plan you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get $5 to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman